es una situación muy fluida
hemos pedido desde la cruz que los
países vecinos
digamos mantengan abiertas sus fronteras
para las personas que busquen protección
y seguridad
y nosotros
como acnur y el sistema de naciones
unidas
está digamos preparada para apoyar a los
gobiernos al poder recibir a las
personas que salgan
de ucrania en qué consiste esta alianza
con los gobiernos locales esta
articulación con los gobiernos que se
comprometen los estados vecinos y en que
se comprometen ustedes para poder llevar
a cabo estos operativos humanitarios y
garantizar la seguridad de las personas
digamos que nosotros ya tenemos stock de
bienes digamos humanitarios de
ayuda humanitaria en los países vecinos
para poder responder a
a estos flujos
y también dentro de ucrania
para para los flujos digamos para las
personas que se desplazan internamente
dentro de ucrania
entonces
se trata de una coordinación con los
gobiernos para poder entregar de la
forma más segura y más efectiva la ayuda
humanitaria que se necesita si vila
también una de las opciones que tienen
muchos ucranianos que son pro rusos es
irse precisamente a la federación de
rusia que su vecino del este también hay
articulación con el gobierno de la
federación de rusia para este operativo
humanitario dado el caso que haya una
salida masiva de ucranianos de su país
no tengo conocimiento específico de eso
pero sí puedo decir que con polonia con
moldova con otros países que
son vecinos de ucrania si ya se ha
tenido
y esa coordinación ha habido un anuncio
recientemente por parte de las
autoridades alemanas dijeron que
estarían dispuestas a recibir a muchos
ciudadanos ucranianos que estén
dispuestos a llegar hasta territorio
alemán escapando de estas ofensivas
pero vemos ahora civil a entonces dos
caras de la moneda vemos como ahora se
le abre las puertas a los ucranianos
para entrar en la unión europea pero
hace unos meses veíamos cómo se les
cerraban las puertas de la frontera de
polonia con belarús para recibir a
ciudadanos iraquíes y a ciudadanos
sirios que también estaban intentando
llegar a la unión europea como
explicarle a la comunidad internacional
estas dos
caras de este balance pues desde el
acnur digamos tenemos una posición muy
muy clara que cualquier persona que esté
buscando
y que necesite protección internacional
que esté huyendo de una guerra o una
persecución que pone en riesgo su vida
debe tener acceso a los sistemas de
asilo y a los territorios entonces
para nosotros no hay esa diferencia